à laisser partir la cavalerie comme
assad ou alors c'est un type qui va voir
son docteur c'est le docteur bénichou
d'accord je connais rentrer dit où mon
jour il parle comme ça mon bonjour de
terminale es bien tama du oui je vais
bien et vous vous êtes vous êtes là
pourquoi il fait vite il ya soixante
plus patient et attendre la j'ai écouté
j'ai un problème
voilà ma femme ne veut plus faire
l'amour avec moi dit alors eh ben je
sais plus quoi faire
vous n'avez qu'à lui parler du qg pas
finie vous vous foutez de moi des gens
que je parle d'une et moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
allez il va nous interpréter deux titres
avant la rentrée comme amour ni moody's
audi l'a 6 570 mille téléspectateurs
moi je pense qu'ils vont pas y toucher
qui vont le moderniser mais 500 series
est espéré stable depuis david guetta
aux platines
oui j'ai hameau
j'ai cette lettre avec lille but il a
cette lettre j'ai pas d'homme c'est quoi
moderniser déçu
pour m
roule à fond
m
pourquoi
tant pour sa mère
bravo les filles merci merci merci des
seuils et maman merci beaucoup je
voulais rester
cela dit aucun débat supersymétrie
beaucoup d'aînés d'amico mais qu'allez
vous parce que c'est vrai qu'on va voir
les les deux à côté à elle rit coccyx
bah voilà j'y vais
[Applaudissements]
oui
mon fils est plus conventionnel
[Applaudissements]